- [Narrator] Let's see if we can add
five and 2/5 to three and 4/5.
Pause this video and see if you
can figure out what this is.
All right, now let's do this together.
We've had a little bit of practice
adding mixed numbers in the past.
And so one way to think about it is,
you could view five and
2/5 as five plus 2/5.
And then to that we're going
to be adding three and 4/5,
which you could view as three plus 4/5.
And then you could just change the order
with which you are adding,
and say, all right,
well, I could say five plus three,
so that's five plus three,
and then to that I could add 2/5 and 4/5,
so, plus 2/5, plus 4/5.
Now what is that going to get me?
Well five plus three is
going to be equal to eight.
Eight plus, and then if I have 2/5,
and I add four more fifths to that,
well now I'm going to have 6/5.
Two of something plus
four of that something
is going to be six of that something,
and the something in this case are fifths.
So now I'm going to have 6/5.
So some of you might be tempted to say,
"Hey, isn't this just going to be equal to
eight and 6/5?"
And you wouldn't be completely
wrong if you said that.
But pause this video and think about
why this feels a little bit off.
Well, the reason why this isn't standard,
is the fractional part
of this mixed number 6/5
is greater than one.
So there's a whole inside of this 6/5.
So the standard way to do this is
see if we can break out that whole.
Now what do I mean by that?
Well I could rewrite eight plus 6/5
as eight plus 6/5 is the same thing
as a whole, or 5/5 plus 1/5.
And why is this useful?
Well 5/5 is the same thing as one.
And so now I can say
this is going to be equal
to eight plus one whole is nine,
that's eight plus the 5/5,
and then what I have leftover is 1/5.
So nine and 1/5.
And so this is the direction
that people will traditionally go in.
Now there's another way
that you could approach it,
which is really the same idea,
we're just writing things
a little bit differently.
We could write this as five and 2/5
plus three and 4/5,
and notice the way that I wrote it.
I put all the fractions
in the fraction column,
I guess you could call it that way,
and I put all of our whole
numbers underneath each other,
and if I had multiple digits here,
I would align them
according to place value.
And then what we could do is we could say,
okay 2/5 plus 4/5 is going to be 6/5.
We could write 6/5 there.
But we say, hey, there's
something a little bit
fishy about 6/5.
That's really the same
thing as 5/5 plus 1/5,
or you could say that's the
same thing as one and 1/5.
6/5 is equal to one and 1/5,
and so what you could do is,
you could write the 1/5 part
in the fractions column,
and then the one well now you're
going to be regrouping that
into our whole numbers,
so you put a one right over there.
Notice, 2/5 plus 4/5 is one and 1/5,
which is the same thing as 6/5.
And then you add the whole number part.
One plus five plus three is nine.
So you get nine and 1/5.
But hopefully you realize
that these are really the same idea,
just different way of writing things